لا تضربني
باتهاماتك الباطلة، اضربني بذلك
العلم مرة أخرى وانظر ماذا سيحدث، لا
تقلق، لا تقلق، لا تقلق، لا
تضربني بهذا العلم،
سألتقط الفيديو، عار عليك أن تقتل،
أنا آخذ  ألتقط الفيديو ألتقط الفيديو
أتحقق من
الفيديو حسنًا إذا كان لدينا أسلاف مشتركون
لا أبدًا
أبدًا أبدًا أبدًا أبدًا واو هذا
جاهل جدًا حسنًا حسنًا يا رفاق نحتاج إلى المغادرة
حسنًا، حسنًا يا رفاق هنا، حسنًا،
ضعوا كاميراتكم
جانبًا، استمتعوا  بقية
يومك لا لا اذهب مع لا يمكنك أن ترى يمكنك أن
ترى كيف تسير الأمور يمكنك أن ترى يمكنك أن ترى
ماذا لدي ماذا تنظر إلى ماذا
تنظر إلى ماذا تنظر يا عزيزتي إلى ماذا تنظر
ليس إلى ماذا تنظر  في
Honey
هاه، إلى ماذا تنظر إلى ماذا
تنظر، احصل على
[الموسيقى]
هنا